from the outside there's little to hint
at the extraordinary work that goes on
inside this building on the inside
however things suddenly become clearer
the sculpture on a landing of the double
helix of DNA for more than two decades
scientists here have worked on the
genetic components of disease and now
they're turning their attention to
covert the founder and CEO of decode
genetics is aiming to test as many in
the Icelandic population as possible to
see how the virus has spread but also
where it came from with some surprising
results we have done more than screened
for the virus we have sequence the virus
from every individual in fact inna in
Iceland so the virus has now basically a
barcode for every part of the world one
of the things that is interesting is
that in the beginning they almost all of
the cases came into the country from the
ASPS and asked who authorities were
trying to contain the spread of the
infection from from the high-risk
countries the virus was sneaking in with
people crammed away from all kinds of
other countries and the most notable
there is Great Britain so it looks like
the virus had a fairly wide spread in
great ways and very very early in this
epidemic very deep in the basement and
extraordinary vault a massive database
of over half the Icelandic populations
genetic material samples willingly given
to help combat disease could it be there
are genetic components to how people
react to covert
there are those who describe this as a
mild cold there are those who end up in
the intensive care unit on a respirator
and then you have everything in-between
we know that women have less tendency to
get infected and man I need to get
infected they don't get a say cos man I
mean what is it that generates this
clinical diversity decode will continue
to genetically sequence positive cases
of covert in Iceland working in tandem
with the health sir
the company is also sampling seemingly
healthy people in the general population
of those who tested positive over 40%
had no symptoms and were quickly
isolated Kari Stefansson rejects the
notion it's been easier for a small
nation to manage kovat yes we may be
fewer others you know about the
countries like the United Kingdom and
the United States have thrown much much
more resources than we do
it is all a question of just using what
you have they they weren't vigilant
enough they didn't react to this early
enough you know the countries are taught
us the methods that we are using in
doing this in a case Larry in place like
Ashland they didn't use it themselves
and that is tragic he insists if there
is a second wave of kovat 19 they'll be
better prepared in Iceland but admits
there is still so much to discover about
this new virus about how it mutates and
spreads and why it impacts people so
differently Michele Clifford Sky News
Rekha Vik Iceland